EMILY YE: Developers
often need a way
to generate
temporary credentials
to access their Cloud accounts.
In this video,
we'll show you how
to generate temporary
Google Cloud Platform IAM
credentials as needed
using HashiCorp Vault.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm Emily, an engineer
working on Google Cloud
Platform, an open source
integration between Cloud
and HashiCorp Vault.
ANDY MANOSKE: And I'm
Andy, a product manager
at HashiCorp on the Vault team.
Vault is a secrets
management tool
that allows you to store,
manage, and control access
to tokens, passwords,
certificates,
and other types of secrets.
EMILY YE: In our last video, we
used HashiCorp Vault to secure
an API key for our '80s-style
arcade game, "Hyperspace,"
and gave our GCE instances
an easy way to access secrets
on GCP using the Vault. Now
let's talk about other ways we
can use Vault on GCP.
Let's say we want to add a daily
leaderboard to our video game.
We'll have it update
at midnight each day,
so it needs to access our
video game data stored
in Spanner at least once a day.
Should we just give it its
own service account key
and access to our
Spanner database?
ANDY MANOSKE: Well, what happens
if someone steals the service
account key?
If you don't have it locked
down as well as the main app,
and it's all on
automated process,
how would you detect
if it gets stolen?
That won't be good.
What if you just gave
it temporary access
to your project, like a
temporary IAM credential?
EMILY YE: Yeah, that would work.
ANDY MANOSKE: So check out the
GCP secrets backend for Vault
then.
A secret backend
in HashiCorp Vault
is a pluggable interface that
can store, generate, or alter
secrets.
The GCP secrets
backend dynamically
creates OAuth access tokens
based on IAM service accounts
and policies.
This means you can
generate credentials
to access GCP as
needed, without needing
to worry about how long
those credentials last.
EMILY YE: That actually sounds
like exactly what I need.
I could see how this would be
useful in other cases, too.
Things like batch jobs or
virtual training accounts
don't need access to your
GCP project for very long
but can be hard
to clean up after.
Developers could use
Vault's GCP secrets
backend to assign the
minimum permissions
to their initial
service accounts
and obtain additional
permissions only as needed.
ANDY MANOSKE: Want
to try it out?
EMILY YE: Sure.
So as you can see, we already
have our Vault server up
and running on GCP
from last time.
We'll show you how a
server admin sets up
the GCP secrets backend and
how a user obtains a new secret
or a GCP OAuth access token.
ANDY MANOSKE: The admin needs
to add configuration details
to his credentials.
The Vault server
uses this config
to make requests to GCP
to set up IAM permissions.
EMILY YE: Next, the admin needs
to add Vault-specific role
sets.
These determine what permissions
the service accounts created
by Vault will have.
The bindings argument
is a configuration file
where we specify GCP IAM roles
to assign to each resource.
ANDY MANOSKE: Can we
take a closer look
at this bindings config file?
EMILY YE: Sure.
Each block in the
configuration file
specifies a resource
and a set of IAM roles.
As you can see in
this block, we've
given the resource name
for our Spanner database
that contains our scoring
data and the role of database
reader.
This tells Vault to give
generated service accounts
permissions to read the scoring
data from the given database.
ANDY MANOSKE: So the secrets
backend is set up then, right?
EMILY YE: Yep.
Let's switch to a
different terminal
now and show how our leaderboard
app gets an access token.
ANDY MANOSKE: To obtain
our OAuth access token,
we read from the creds
endpoint, specifying
the rule set we want to
generate the token under.
Vault generates the token using
a service account it creates
and then returns this token.
EMILY YE: When the TTL,
or Time To Live, is up,
Vault revokes the lease and
the access token in turn.
We can then use this OAuth
token to call the Spanner API.
Now that we've finished
our request of Spanner,
we don't need access.
Let's revoke this
token manually.
That was really easy to do.
Andy, if other
developers have questions
on setting this
backend up, where
can they get more information?
ANDY MANOSKE: So the
vaultproject.io page and look
up documentation on the
GCP secrets backend.
EMILY YE: Thanks, Andy.
You can also check
out other information
for running Vault
on GCP, including
using the GCP
authentication backends
or using GCP with
other HashiCorp tools,
like Terraform.
See the links in
description below.
Bye.
ANDY MANOSKE: Bye.
EMILY YE: Thanks,
everyone, for watching.
We hope you found this series on
using HashiCorp Vault with GCP
helpful.
Check out the links
in the description
below, and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel.